gauthier rybinski bonjour on vient
d'apprendre il ya quelques instants
qu'une délégation russe venait de partir
de quitter moscou pour mener ces
nouveaux échanges nouveau round de
pourparlers le troisième je crois pour
pour tenter d'avancer on a vu ce que ça
avait donné jusqu'ici on voit aussi la
réaction kiev sur ces corridors
humanitaires fin de nous recevoir en
l'état actuel de la de la situation ça
peut donner quoi de nouveau cessé
échangés sont importants il faut
continuer malgré tout à discuter on se
fait une carte vous êtes d'accord ça
peut aider alors on va la regarder vous
allez comprendre écoutez c'est pour
parler c'est toujours ça on n'a pas
exactement les moyens souvent de faire
le faire les difficiles maintenant quel
est le problème de ces de ces corridors
vous voyez il va y en avoir plusieurs et
va y avoir entre kiev et la biélorussie
il va y en avoir entre
actifs et la russie et puis à partir de
marioupol deux possibilités soit aller
vers la russie soit allé vers
l'intérieur de l'ukraine bon vous voyez
tout de suite qu'il ya un problème des
réfugiés ukrainiens de kiev par exemple
alan biélorussie qui est associé à
moscou qu'elle sorte leur être réservé
pareil pour les réfugiés de grade tiff
qui vont se retrouver en russie
comment vont ils être traitées par les
russes se sont aussi ce sont des
ukrainiens illya que ceux de marioupol
qui peuvent espérer avoir un traitement
à peu près correct puisque les intérêts
en ukraine donc la question est bien là
et c'est pour ça qu'il y à une manoeuvre
de la part de vladimir poutine qui a dit
c'est à la demande expresse des manuels
macron or l'elysée a démenti l'elysée a
dit le droit humanitaire international
c'est pas de permettre uniquement les
corridors humanitaires c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un cessez le feu qui
puisse ensuite permettre des corridors
humanitaires cessez le feu et retrait
sur certains endroits pour pouvoir
permettre ces corridors donc l'idée
qu'il ya derrière de vladimir poutine
c'est bien de dire moi je suis l'agressé
et les ukrainiens sont les agresseurs
donc ce qu'on peut raisonnablement
penser c'est que toutes ces personnes
qui vont se réfugier soit en biélorussie
soit en russie
a priori soit des russes soient des
russophones soit des personnes
favorables la dîmière bouteille on voit
bien la difficulté est pour emmanuel
macron évidemment en première ligne du
fait de sa posture président présidence
tournante de l'union européenne
on sent bien les européens aujourd'hui
coincé entre deux feux ya cette volonté
évidemment d'aider les ukrainiens mais
de ne pas franchir ces lignes rouges au
vu des menaces russe régulièrement
avancé oui d'une certaine manière ils ne
peuvent s'en prendre qu'à eux mêmes
parce que ça fait 22 ans un peu moins
disons 15 ans que l'union européenne
hors mis à part quelques exceptions
notables cette union européenne dit il
faut comprendre vladimir poutine c'est à
dire qu'il faut admettre ce qu'il veut
ça veut dire qu'il faut admettre la
dictature et donc à partir de là on peut
s'entendre de manière rationnelle avec
l'annuaire poutine la guerre
d'aujourd'hui prouve que non est ce que
nous avons raté c'était la voix des
russes qui dès 2004 2005 disait
attention c'est une dictature attention
les droits sont bafoués et en europe ou
aux états unis on disait oui ni les
russes qui sont toujours d'ailleurs
considéré par ces gens là comme des ours
russe troud fruste on les laisser dans
le dans la dans la panade dans la
dictature dans l'oppression et la
coercition donc que s'est il passé c'est
qu'on a ignoré tout ça alors maintenant
on se rattrape en disant oui on a
compris vladimir poutine est un homme
qui est animé de passion dévastatrice et
oui on se rattrape mais deux fêtes on a
un retard terrible dans la diplomatie
qui explique qu'aujourd'hui les voies
diplomatiques soit encore plus ténue
qu'autrefois parce que vladimir poutine
a appris à avoir un boulevard devant lui
beaucoup estiment que la solution va au
final venir des russes eux-mêmes les
russes qui sont en train de voir
l'ampleur évidemment les conséquences un
de ces de ces sanctions qui peuvent le
voir n'est qu'un début oui quand ils
peuvent le voir effectivement
les russes qui manifestent aussi treize
mille personnes ont déjà été arrêtées
par la police depuis le début de cette
crise ça ne peut venir que d'eux
finalement la fin la fondamentalement
oui ça veut dire que c'est exactement
l'inversé de ce que je disais c'est à
dire qu'il faut parler aux russes et
isolé poutine alors qu'on a fait l'un
versent jusqu'à présent bon on va pas
refaire l'histoire mais c'est ça le
problème c'est les moyens d'information
dont il dispose et y en a très peu vous
avez vu tous ses organes qui sont
admirables de courage qui ont été fermés
ou qui sont obligés de trouver des
astuces des subterfuges pour continuer à
émettre ou à diffuser c'est très
compliqué et le problème avec les russes
c'est que d'abord il ya une majorité qui
suit outin mais même ceux qui ont l'idée
de critiquer et de se dresser et ce qui
est très difficile ils sont si vous
voulez un peu perçu comme des
hurluberlus par les autres russes tout
simplement et là on n'y peut rien c'est
que les russes n'ont pas connu la
démocratie sauf un tout petit passage à
l'époque de eltsine qui a été
catastrophique pour des tas d'autres
raisons économiques et culturels mais
sinon c'était le tsarisme union
soviétique ce petit passage et vladimir
poutine bas il faut oui malheureusement
ça risque de durer très longtemps à
moins qu'il y ait un renversement de
régime ça c'est une autre hypothèse
merci beaucoup gauthier pour le
décryptage on vient